Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192. David P We last week I told you
Joe Biden's approval rating is low and some people
actually became furious with me because of that.
This voicemail is a parody of those people.
I'll tell you more about it in a moment.
Speaker 5: Hello, this is Alan from
Jersey. I'm so outraged that you, David,
how dare you report accurate information on Joe
Biden's approval rating? We need you to lie and
distort exactly the same as Fox News does, except
on the left. So Fox News lies and distorts about
Trump. You need to lie and distort about Biden.
You write the truth about his approval ratings.
I'm so outraged. Are you telling the truth that
I've had to sign up for 10 to 15 memberships
just so I can cancel memberships in
disapproval? It's exactly like flushing
your toilet. You need to do it 10 to 15 times.
Speaker 1: Okay, now this guy is joking. But in
all seriousness, I mentioned this on a stream
the other day. I got emails after reporting
that Joe Biden's approval rating is low. Now,
that's not my opinion of Joe Biden and it's
not my poll. I'm just reporting I've reported
to people when George W Bush was president,
I would tell you his approval. And when Obama
was president, I would tell you his approval.
And when Trump was president, I would tell you his
approval. Now, I tell you, Joe Biden's approval,
which is low, guys, it's low. I'm not going to lie
to you. And I had one person right in saying what,
David? You're mad that Biden hasn't given
everybody a pony like. No, that story wasn't
about my opinion. That story was what is his
approval rating? Other people saying I shouldn't
be poisoning the well by mentioning that his
approval rating is low. What does that even mean?
What are you talking about? Are you saying I
should hide information or lie to the audience?
It's crazy. And yes, a handful of people
canceled memberships because they said,
Hey, guys. Joe Biden's approval rating isn't
doing so well. This is what I'm talking about.
The right spends a weekend funding a glitzy event
with pyrotechnics, making stars out of their
lunatic politicians, coalescing activity and
activism and energy. And meanwhile, over here,
like David, you mentioned Biden's approval rating.
I'm canceling my $5 a month membership. It's
concerning stuff. I've said it before. It's very
concerning. On today's bonus show, by the way,
the bonus show, Ron DeSantis is now going
around saying Biden's stimulus caused inflation.
So they should send the money to Floridians.
But it's like that won't actually change the
inflationary element of it. A students in a Dallas
school district are now going to be mandated to
wear a clear backpacks in order to make it evident
if there are guns in the backpacks, that's where
we are. And Missouri Democrats after video of
Republican Senator Josh Hawley was released of him
running out of the Capitol on January 6th.
They are doing a hall in Hawley five K race,
sort of making fun of Josh Hawley. We will
talk about that and more on today's bonus
show. Don't Miss Tomorrow evening's Town Hall, 6
p.m. Eastern, 3 p.m. Pacific. It will be streaming
live on Pacman live and everybody will be
welcome to call in through the discord at
David Pakman dot com slash discord and yes our
website members will get priority participation
on the town hall. You can sign up at join pacman
dot com and use the coupon code. Big voting 22
to get a discount. Looking forward to seeing
everybody number one on today's bonus show
and number two during the town
hall event tomorrow see you that.